- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is have goals.
Over to you Eric Worre.
(cockerel crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- My future plan is
about this thick, typed.
It's usually about 40 pages or so.
And it includes everything.
And today, more than
ever, what you'll find
with top leaders, what you'll
find with successful people,
is they're forward thinking,
they're future thinking
and that future starts
to pull them towards
those objectives.
So I set my goals pretty high
and I've set my calendar far in advance,
I'm planning, I still
have some spontaneity,
room for spontaneity, but more and more,
as the demands on my time
are growing exponentially,
I have to plan and what I've,
I've done this for, gosh, 25 years,
so look back and look forward.
Look back, take inventory, be honest,
and look forward and map it out.
So I want you to think about short-term,
mid-term, long-term goals
for you, personally and for your team.
- When you have specific goals,
you're much more likely to follow through.
When you know where you're going,
and you've clearly defined it,
you're much more likely to
achieve and hit that target.
The challenge then becomes making sure
you have meaningful
goals that support you.
I look at my Mastermind Group,
there's a collection of entrepreneurs,
we get together once a month,
and we have goals as a part of what we do.
There's short-term goals, and
what you're going to get done
before the end of next month,
so before you come and meet
at the next meeting,
here are the three things
that you need to do in your business
and in your life to make
some forward progress.
And it's self-defined, it's not
me saying here's your goals,
you need to come with your goals
and say here's what I need to get done
before the end of our next meeting
and then we have an annual goal.
By December 31st of this year,
what does your business look like?
And we force it to be a quantifiable goal,
it has to be specific, we
have to be able to measure it,
it's not just I want to
feel happy about my life,
it's got to be something that's tangible.
Most people pick a revenue goal
cos that's a significant,
meaningful goal in their business,
it doesn't have to be revenue,
but it has to be quantifiable.
So I have goals, I have a goal
to hit a million YouTube
subscribers on my channel,
it's not just that that's
the goal that I want
and when I accomplish
that, then it's game over,
then I've won, I still
respect and enjoy the process,
I enjoy making the videos much more
than just hitting that goal but that goal,
allows me to align my plans.
I have a goal to hit
gold in Living Legends
and so I have a plan to
work on accomplishing that
and not all of your goals
need to be growth-oriented,
sometimes a goal is just
maintaining your habits.
Now I have a goal to be a good husband.
If that's your goal, just in itself,
it's hard to live up to
because what does that mean?
It's not specific enough.
And so for me, there's three
things that I do everyday
that's on my list, that
means being a good husband,
things that are important to my wife
and important for me and so I
try to do these three things
every single day and when I do that,
then I've kind of checked the boxes,
like I'm doing the
things that I need to do
to be a good husband.
And so when you can quantify,
when you can get specific around the goal,
you're much more likely
to accomplish that goal.
The trick then becomes making sure
that you have goals that support you
in being that best version of yourself.
Do you know what a good picture
looks like in the future?
Do you have a goal that is
motivating and meaningful to you?
So as an example, I was listening
to a motivational DVD or CD, years ago
and the guy's talking about goal setting
and he's talking about
write down your goals,
and he's very energetic,
and, you know, if you
want to make a sculpture,
write down make a sculpture,
if you want to make a painting,
write down make a painting
and so, his energy influenced
me to want those things,
yeah, yeah, I want to make a sculpture,
write make a sculpture, I
want to make a painting too,
look at how exciting that sounds,
I want to make a painting
and then when I came back to
it, at the end of the day,
I don't really want to make a sculpture,
I don't really want to make a painting
and so having goals like that
didn't ultimately serve me
and so that's the trick, figuring out
what are the goals that if
you accomplish these things,
it's going to serve you
playing at the level
that you want to play at,
having the clarity to
understand where you want to go
and writing those things down,
because if you can
accomplish those things,
it means that you are living
the life that you want to live
and once you get really specific, again,
you're much more likely to follow through
than if you have no
game plan and no goals.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious, what are three of your goals?
In your life or in your business,
what are three goals that if you hit,
it's going to make you feel really good
and it's a sign that your life
and your business are on track.
Leave it in the comments below,
super curious to find out,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Juha Sipinen,
I hope I pronounced that okay,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really,
really, really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying it.
Thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- What's up Believe Nation,
for those of you who
want a little more detail
on creating goals and the importance
to your life and business,
I think you're going to enjoy
these special bonus clips.
- I want to talk a little bit about goals,
along the lines of how do you lose
37 pounds and write a book?
I'm just going to kind of
give you that as an example.
For 24 years of my adult life, by choice,
I weighed well over 200 pounds.
I say by choice, because you see,
I have never accidentally eaten anything.
(audience laughs)
I mean it's always been deliberate,
and when I choose to eat too much today,
I have chosen to weigh too much tomorrow.
You can choose to set goals
and realize your potential
or you can choose not to set them.
Now, if you choose not to set them,
you've got to understand
that the consequences
are not going to be good down the road.
For 24 years I was going
to lose that weight,
as a matter of fact, in 24 years
I lost several thousand pounds of weight.
How many of you already know
exactly what I'm talking about?
But it wasn't until I wrote it down,
put a date on it, listed the
obstacles I had to overcome,
identified the people, the
groups, the organizations
I needed to work with,
spelled out a plan of action,
set that time limit in there,
and identified all of the benefits to me,
it was only when I did that
that the goal became a
reality and I lost the weight.
For 10 or 15 years I was
going to write a book,
you know anybody who's going to
do just a whole lot of things, folks?
I was going to write a book.
But it wasn't until I
got busy writing the book
and writing the plans first,
before the book ever
materialized now if this sounds
like I'm trying to sell
you on having goals,
how many of you are getting close already?
How many of you are becoming convinced
quite quickly that you
need to have those goals?
There's no question about it.
The immortal J. C. Penney,
many, many years ago,
said give me a stock clerk with a goal
and I'll give you a
man who'll make history
but give me a man without a goal
and I'll give you a stock clerk.
Now the interesting thing is
goals do not care who has them
and let me give you a classic
example of the way they work.
In 1950, a war torn, devastated Japan,
a nation that had lost an
incredibly high percentage
of its young men, their
cities were in ruins,
they'd been bombed out, but in 1950,
they got together, they meaning
industry and government,
got together and set a goal.
The goal was, we're going
to be the number one
nation in the world during the 1950s
in the production of textiles.
In 1959, ladies and gentlemen,
they accomplished that objective.
In 1960 they set another goal.
We're going to be the number
one nation in the world
in the production of steel.
Now, when you understand
there's no iron ore
in Japan of any significance,
there's no coal of any significance there,
we're going to be the number
one nation in the world
in the production of steel,
it seems like an absurd goal
and yet they reached their objective,
they'd taken all of the steps.
In 1970, the Japanese set another goal,
they said during the 70s,
we'll be the number one nation
in the world in the
production of automobiles.
They missed it folks, one year.
It took 'em until 1980.
In 1980, they set another goal
and this time their goal
was we're going to be
the number one nation in the world
in the production of
computers and electronics.
Yes, indeed, ladies and gentlemen,
you absolutely must have those goals.
- The general principle
is I am pro goal, right?
I am pro paramaters, you know?
There is this good story in the book about
a woman named Elise Blaha Cripe
who is a serial crafter and
she makes all this stuff
and she shares it with the world
and she's incredibly prolific
and her whole advice is,
she says people are always telling you
to think outside the
box, she says my advice,
is to get in the box,
basically, make yourself a box,
make yourself these parameters,
these goals, whatever,
again, it's not something
that's being imposed on you,
that's really the clear point,
it's not like someone's
saying here's your goal,
here's what you should do, no, it's you,
things that you select for yourself
but I believe there's so much possibility
in those parameters, or
in those constraints,
as we talked about, so whether it's
my goal is to climb Mount Everest
or maybe it's the 10
mountains, or something,
and stages are also good.
Set stages or milestones,
the levels in Mario Brothers,
for me, it was 50
countries, 100 countries,
then it was every continent,
once I'd finished all of
Africa, that was a big thing.
So I do think it's important
to celebrate small wins along the way.